hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach hi as we all figured
out in the last playthrough I had I got
ported to that other dimension and I got
ported to that area but I could never
get out I confirm this with some people
I would never be able to get out of
there here so I have to start a new game
I know I know it's it's it sucks because
I gotten so far eight but I mean it's
like what can you do about it
so I don't know nap seed I was looking
up more stuff about the map seed and I'm
wondering fight sex sex sex yeah I'm
wondering what I could do if I could get
a good map seed I saw some other people
posting map seeds that might have been
good but I kind of want to leave a
little bit of mystery to it oh did I put
the intro sequence again I did I'm an
idiot oh there goes mark apone eight
golly
can't believe it keep losing all these
all these all these super hardcore Call
of Duty names I'm gonna try not to
let's just go random hopefully I'll be
able to get a key card and get on my way
that last seat was so good because I
barely saw scp-173 that's a good thing
that's a good thing good for me you all
I mean I may get setbacks here but like
I was was SCP oh7 be on the live stream
I'm persistent
why is this red what is that
ah hey did that need to be like that ha
ha ha I just remembered how much I don't
like this ah scp-956
to WC oh nothing ever good happens in
the bathroom horror stories bathrooms
are a bad place to be art woman's first
whoa what was that what was that oh god
I remember how much I hate this game
hi wait a minute these are exactly the
same I don't see anything I can get what
was that
Oh No ha he's in there he's in there I
see oh I tell you all you moved oh you
moved there again alright screw that I'm
not even gonna try to get out you're
just a douche your jet juice
I'm going back I'm gonna make my own bad
evarin wait a minute okay I was very
very worried for a second there actually
I shouldn't be too worried because if I
go far enough away scp-173 will be
spawned to an area
all right oh I hate these dark hallways
I hate dark Oh another SCP uh-huh oh
this is the guy
oh this is this is the thing I need to
find a key card I know there was another
way that you go oh I need to find a key
card now oh you need to find a key card
this is it girls
I'm with that's the thing that can turn
the cue cards in the veil off the card
and I discovered that it actually did
change the gas mask I looked it up and
it made the gas back so that when I put
it on I never run out of run juice you
know you know what I mean oh come on
that's area I think there's anything
else here that I need damn it Passover
for a key card
I'm just getting a bunch out of here I
don't like that at all it's not happy
fun times over there nothing that I need
hopefully by the time I get back won 7-3
will be gone
I don't like being forced to go near
that that is not cool here we go then
he's still there doesn't look like he's
there but you know I've been wrong about
that before hook come on come on Kermit
where are you
Rory not there yeah I thought okay I
don't eat another gas mask huh oh no no
no no give me a key card oh why is that
black was that distant look
god I hate this game so much I value be
ready
show me you okay there's the sat-nav
this way get the side now nope I'm not
going into that pocket dimension I don't
care what that guy wants I'm not going
in there that's where okay I'm gonna go
back all right I'm gonna go back because
the the change II metier why is there a
black wall there now don't be like that
ah up go go go go
like a mouse let's talk about what is
that so then it was it someone else
hey let me see if I can go in here I'm
actually worried about this
whoops a be worried I'm already worried
what am I talking about
I'm very good hang on one side
why is my camera like pulling towards
that that's probably a bad thing
why is my camera pulling towards that
whoa hey whoa oh don't get dark on me
whoa what are you doing please viewing
by hi hi I'm just curious
Oh what was that
hey no I don't even know what that was
how can someone how could someone sit
here when that's there why would they
why would they do that
Oh God I know you guys want me to look
at it again so I'm gonna close my eyes
and you're gonna look at it ha ha ha
even looking at it
I am oh I love her ah I figured that my
god I didn't even know if I was looking
at it but ha ha ha ok now let's see
where this thing is I think I read about
it it causes hallucinations whenever you
look at it through like a camera or
something which is why that was
happening but if you're with it you know
nothing happened whoa like if you're
here whoa whoa Joe none
ah nah come on
no not right pillow old guy oh come on
man
what the f I was radical Larry oh man I
hate him so much
Oh rad Oh Larry
oh come on I don't have a lot of time up
radical Larry I don't have time to deal
with your [ __ ] hockey but what oh no mom
no
I know why why music Oh Boober I need to
go bedroom oh come on he's gonna come to
the wall oh no no no no come on
oh don't be like that oh oh oh I don't
wanna come on radical Larry leave me
alone did I actually get away from him
I hope so cuz I just saved all right so
anyway go to five very fine drop in um
well I wonder if I can drop more stuff
in at once let's try probably not apply
bad idea probably a bad idea
game not meant to handle this here we go
what who that cami
the battery oh I'm an idiot
oh I'm an idiot ah well I'm just stupid
then hey even I haven't even put the
battery in there I was thinking that
maybe the battery could turn into some
like super thing that would never be
like put paper in I'm curious least
curious gars dumping like my hole in the
door in there not the batteries Oh cuz
screw that
I like this
get out ooh papers they change it all
no no did they 89 5 what so 79
microcomputer uh what oh it's that thing
oh yeah that thing oh maybe they change
to like random papers that's that thing
again all right I don't need the papers
I'm gonna dump all the papers anyway cuz
they're stupid
no yeah okay no this this is my gas mask
hey a guard no don't go what what what
what are you what that weird the gas
mask balls I was that one to one
oh that one to one
oh let's try this again maybe a little
trimming turn plane card into an omni
card Wow oh wait I want to say I wanted
to get into the paper
come on done Omni card a MasterCard what
what it but why
what no give me money give me a card
get me an omni card come on don't be
like that why would you turn into a
plate ah come on
I didn't do the paper due next time
ah no yargh okay anyway I'm all I have
time for this episode so thank you all
so much for watching check out all the
Let's Plays I've done over there in the
annotation dragon compilation playlist
over there thank you so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye